hi thank you for doing this um I was
hoping you could talk a little bit more
about why the Pentagon decided to
declassify the video of the Drone and
whether or not releasing it you know
increase the risk of Russia framing this
conflict instead of being a conflict
between Russia and Ukraine but be being
between Russia and the West
yeah thanks Tara so first of all it's
not unusual for us to release imagery of
unsafe unprofessional incidents we've
done that in other situations and so
particularly in this case given the
Reckless and dangerous behavior and to
demonstrate publicly
what type of actions the Russians had
taken we felt that it was important to
provide this imagery certainly there are
certain considerations that we have to
take into account when dealing with
imagery to include the classification to
ensure that we're not inadvertently
putting out sensitive information but in
this case we were able to work through
that and provide that as far as you know
Russian perceptions again I think it's
important to take a step back and look
at the big picture here the United
States focus in the region the focus
with Ukraine is solely on providing
Ukraine with the support that it needs
to defend itself you've heard us say
before that Ukraine has a right to
defend itself and we have a right to
help them alongside the International
Community to do that so so the United
States does not seek conflict with
Russia we do not seek escalation with
Russia and so we're going to continue to
stay focused on our primary mission in
the Ukraine area which is supporting
Ukraine in its fight
the class declassifying the video and
releasing it
you know Russia has suggested that it
didn't show the actual contact
how does this really just counter that
narrative and show that this happened
the way that the Pentagon has said it
has yeah well I I think that our words
and our actions speak for themselves and
similarly Russia's inaccurate
information false information
obstacation grasping at straws changing
narratives also speaks for itself so
we're going to stay focused on the facts
and we're going to stay focused on our
mission let me go to the next question
Liz
first part of my questions are um did
the U.S ask for an apology from Russia
on taking down the Drone and did Russia
offer an apology
I know we did not ask for an apology
again our Focus was on highlighting the
fact as we've made very clear publicly
and privately that the United States
will continue to fly and operate in
international airspace in accordance
with international law
and my second part is it's come out that
Russian officials ordered the pilots to
be aggressive towards the Drone and
today the centcom commander told the
Senate armed services committee that
he's seen increased Russian aggression
in the Middle East is this something
that the U.S is concerned about does the
U.S have any promises that Russia will
decrease its its aggression
um so Liz what I would tell you is that
again our focus is on conducting our
operations in support of our national
security interests our our allies and
our partners around the world ultimately
the Russian military and the Russian
government is responsible for its own
behavior and when that behavior is
unsafe and unprofessional we're going to
call it out as we've done in this case
and so that it will continue to be our
Focus you've heard secretary Austin
you've heard General Hecker in Europe
and others call on the Russians to be
safe and professional in conducting
their operations and that would be the
expectation going forward thank you will
um so secretary Austin has said that um
the U.S will continue to operate to fly
wherever international law allows in
light of that has the U.S operated mq-9s
over the Black Sea since um since the
collision and crash
so I'm not going to get into talking
about uh specific missions routes
timelines of operations I think
secretary Austin was pretty clear that
we're going to continue to fly and
operate in international airspace or
International allows and that includes
the Black Sea region thank you Travis